la guerre en Ukraine avec C wizi donc
celle du président turc redchepta
hyperdoğan et du Secrétaire général de
l'ONU dans le pays ce sera à vive dans
l'ouest de l'Ukraine où les deux hommes
s'entretiendront notamment avec le
président Zelinski au cœur des
discussions bien sûr les exportations de
céréales kankara souhaite augmenter mais
également le nucléaire et la situation
surtout autour de la centrale de zaporig
Jack pour en apprendre plus on va tout
de suite se diriger vers Kiev justement
où nous attend l'envoyé spécial de
France 24 mais Lina Huet bonjour Mélina
Mélina qu’est-ce qui est au programme
exactement de cette rencontre entre les
trois hommes
bien écoutez vous l'avez dit Antoine la
priorité de cette rencontre c'est de
parler de cet accord sur l'exportation
des céréales qui ont le rappelle a été
signé le 22 juillet dernier c'est-à-dire
il y a presque quatre semaines le
premier navire marchand qui avait quitté
l'un des trois grands ports d'allier ça
dans le sud de l'Ukraine est parti le
premier août depuis une vingtaine a déjà
fait le voyage vers différents pays en
passant évidemment par la Turquie donc
la présence de reshop taille père douane
et d'Antonio guteres elle n'est pas
anecdotique et anecdotique évidemment
symbolique pour la simple et bonne
raison que c'est sous la rigide que cet
accord a été signé de manière indirecte
avec la Russie alors il se satisfait de
cet accord de ces nouveaux départs de
navires marchand mais il trouve que la
cadence n'est peut-être pas assez
importante en tout cas avant la guerre
il faut savoir que il y avait environ 5
millions de tonnes de céréales qui
quittent de céréales qui quittaient les
pores d'adsa par mois environ une
centaine de navires marchands on est
très très loin de cette cadence
actuellement il y avait pendant plus de
5 mois environ 20 millions de tonnes de
céréales qui étaient bloquées dans des
silos dans les ports d'Odessa les trois
grands ports dont celui de la ville du
même nom et celui de tchernomorsk et
puis il y a une nouvelle récolte qui
arrive et donc vont à s'additionner à
ses 20 millions de tonnes de céréales 20
à 25 millions de tonnes supplémentaires
donc 45 millions au total à devoir
exporter donc c'est la première raison
de cette visite elle vive et puis
ensuite il y aura des discussions très
probablement sur la centrale de Zapo
Legends c'est pas encore si ardoune va
participer à cette discussion avec
volozimmers zellenski et Antonio guteres
mais en tout cas en tout cas c'est une
préoccupation énorme pour la communauté
internationale le Conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU était réuni en urgence pour
discuter des frappes qui touchent cette
centrale nucléaire qui est la plus
puissante d'Europe qui fournit 20%
d'électricité à l'Ukraine et qui donc
est la cible de frappe dont s'accuse
mutuellement la Russie et l'Ukraine le
but c'est de demander la
démilitarisation de cette zone mais
également l'envoi d'observateurs
internationaux pour définir qui sont à
l'origine des frappes merci beaucoup
Mélina pour toutes ces précisions Mélina
Huet envoyé spécial de France 24 en
Ukraine donc